okay today I'm going to talk to you
about electrolysis now we can figure out
what electrolysis means just by looking
at the word the bit that says electro
shows us we use electricity and the bit
that says lysis lysis means either
splitting or separating so all it means
is using electricity to split or
separate a substance the specific
example that we're going to look at is
with splitting potassium chloride now
potassium chloride is an ionic compound
that's held together by these strong
ionic bonds we might want to use
electrolysis in order to get potassium
all by itself so we've got potassium
metal all by itself and to get chlorine
gas or by itself but the moment as we
can see they are not separated okay so
let me show you how this works because
what we need for electrolysis to happen
is we need a power supply supply and
electricity or electric current rather
and we need two electrodes these
electrodes are often made out of things
such as graphite it's important that
they are inert or unreactive so this
electrode here is the positive one
called the anode so anode is positive
and cathode is the name of the negative
one now there's a nice way of
remembering this by thinking of panic
now panic helps us to remember because
it helps us to think positive anode
negative is cathode so this little thing
here can help us remember which one of
the electrodes is which so in order to
separate our potassium and our chlorine
we can't do it while other this
substance is solid because they're held
in place the different ions are held in
place by these strong ionic bonds so the
first thing we need to do is melt it by
melting it we are breaking the bonds so
these ion
are free to move okay so we have melted
this potassium chloride so these ions
are free to move so let's just have a
think about what that is going to look
like so we now have these electrodes
dipped into our molten potassium and
chloride I'm just going to do a couple
of each of the ions to show that they
are now free to move because they are
molten because it's now a liquid okay
now as soon as we start passing an
electric current through we're going to
have a particular thing happening we are
going to have our ions moving to one or
the other electrode now the golden rule
is opposites attract so this negative
chloride ion is going to be attracted to
our positive anode as is this here and
our positive potassium ions are going to
be attracted to our negative cathode
okay now really quickly just to explain
why I know potassium has a plus charge
and chlorine has a minus charge if we
cast our minds back potassium is in
Group one of the periodic table which
means it needs to lose one electron to
form an ion therefore k plus and
chlorine is in group seven of the
periodic table so it needs to gain one
electron to form an ion therefore
forming CL - please watch a video about
forming ions or ionic bonding to get
more explanation about that so we know
it each of these electrodes this one
here the tussin is going to form and
this one here chlorine gas is going to
form now we need to know about the
equations for each of these because
there is there's either electrons are
being gained or lost at either of these
different electrodes now there's a
really nice way of remembering this
which is this acronym here
called oil-rig now what this stands for
is oxidation is loss reduction is gain
now you may be thinking this is gain or
loss of what it's a gain a loss of
electrons okay so if we lose electrons
its oxidation if we gain electrons its
reduction now let's think about what's
happening at the cathode right here now
we have potassium ions and I know for a
fact that I'm going to eventually form
but solid potassium and I'm going to do
this either by gaining electrons or
losing electrons now if I don't
carefully at this I can see that my
potassium has a positive charge here so
I know I know that an electrons have a
negative charge so I know that I need to
gain one electron in order to someone
positive and my negative balance out
cancel each other out to form my
potassium now I've gained electrons so I
know for a fact that this here is an
example of reduction so what's happening
at the anode now I know that I'm going
to start off with chloride ions and I
know that I'm going to produce chlorine
gas
now chlorine gas has the formula CL 2 so
to balance that I know I need to put a 2
here right now am I going to have gained
electrons or lost electrons now because
it's negative I need to lose electrons
so lose that negativity to get to this
chlorine gas here so to show that I show
that I started off with my chloride ions
and I ended up with chlorine plus these
two electrons because these electrons
have been lost from these chloride ions
now this because I've lost electrons I
know for a fact that this process is
oxidation
so just a recap electrolysis means
splitting of a compound using
electricity we have a positive anode and
a negative cathode our sample needs to
be melted in order to be separated and
oxidation is loss reduction is gain of
electrons and then here a couple of
examples and half equations at the
bottom as well
thank you